we are living in the flop culture
everybody needs to pretend every
microaggression
is going to knock them on the floor and
they're all going to arrive in pain
lebron james he is apparently a
professional athlete
he's a full-time leftist political
activist but i guess he plays a
some sport as well he was recently in
in hot water on social media because
lebron james as you might know is one
one prone to exaggerating his injuries
so he was sort of i guess kind of felt
and anyway
he uh some guy barely like breathes on
him and he flops over he's
writhing on the floor and he's in
immense
[Applause]
so now they're all fighting on the court
okay very
very very silly stuff so very so there
was another one of these
that happened uh uh was it last week
yeah another
another one here we go someone barely
breathes on lebron james
and then up there oh no he's scared you
almost did a somersault
oh he's down look at it so anderson will
shoot two free throws
lebron james is a very big muscular guy
and he he's sort of known for doing this
the reason i bring it up is not because
i care about lebron james or
basketball or sports really generally
it's because this is our whole culture
we are living
in the flop culture where everybody
needs to pretend like every little
possible perceived maybe micro
aggression
is going to knock them on the floor and
they're all going to arrive in pain
a lot of people are making fun of lebron
james because he flops and he rides
and he cries and he lays very
performative
in in his uh grief and
grievance but it's not just on the court
he does that
politically as well lebron james came
out and said that black men cannot walk
out the door
in this country without being hunted
down by racist whites do you remember
that
that is very humiliating for him he
should be ashamed it's
womanish behavior not womanly it's
womanly is good when a woman behaves
like a woman
when a man behaves like a woman that's
womanish
it's it's a very pathetic sort of
behavior
but lebron does it because our culture
no longer rewards
forbearance patience grit
courage manliness we don't we don't
reward that
we reward whining and crying and
complaining
and pouting and grievance that's what we
reward now so
you're going to get more of that that's
that's how incentives work right
all we hear and specifically i guess in
the case of lebron james all we hear
is how racist and by racist we mean
anti-black this country is it's racist
it's in our core it's in our dna
yo ring that bell like and subscribe
also though while i've got you while
i've got your attention
i know you're on youtube head on over to
apple podcasts
spotify google play wherever you listen
to your podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show we
want to avoid all sorts of shenanigans
that the big tech companies play
we want to make sure you are always
getting those updates
if you wouldn't mind leave a five star
review we sure do like that i very much
appreciate that we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you